welcome to this video you like the chest
cube content so I'm doing one more it
Cindy Chester quick Tony 30 minutes and
this is actually bullet time control so
one minute not my usual time but I do my
best yeah classical I'm Kings an onion
actually glad that have black here
because this is easier to play as black
you always have the the King site play
now black it's already crashing through
here and he resigned okay so let's see
what happens here I always have to
remember too funny opening line here not
really intentional maybe I can get some
some quick attack out of this it's
bullet chess after all there's a pin on
the default
so I want two peas at the end far down
on the clock this is also due to the
time handicap typical here for the tour
the war zone from it yeah I need to get
this bloody paw be three i know i can
easily support to the beep on wins the
rook now i can promote here i'll only
need to be cautious for stalemates yeah
that's it now okay yeah some guy is
three games in that's not so not so easy
to do for me at least I I tend to at
least we do you want to do that I tend
to to need some time not winning that
claim
there are fairly solid position here and
from the scandinavian center counter
let's get the queens of this should be
helpful yeah typical endgame very often
this type of endgame arises from the
caro-kann and one major point is the age
corner that restricts black but also can
be your weakness for white as here yeah
he attacked it yeah slightly annoying
but should be fairly solid him alright
f-4s coming ok yeah blunder dead but
there are lots of pawns
I'll need my king definitely we're
forfeited on time yeah great from this
position oh my god ah I wasn't starting
the game yeah there was all centerra
with the finish of the last game but I'm
living that on time under you yeah I
don't play bullet regularly at the
moment and this shows you simply need
the speedy tail and if you don't do not
play that much it quite often can be a
problem maybe I can activate here oh
this was a risky move okay that's just a
corner really
yeah let's let's keep this a five-point
and now snatch this one it's also three
hanging yeah I get some too this is very
strong those pawns in the center and in
drugs you will now well only tenth place
but I'm not winning quickly and I lost
this this one a game we should also
switch to 1e form for quicker win so but
this is a relatively high rated guy so
at ok I'll try an hour Direct refutation
of this of this setup did not really
work out
I'm okay but it's nothing I'm nothing
spectacular I used to quick him he's too
quick I thought I can just about defend
this but I cannot mmm that's bad
maybe that's not so clear actually I'm
not mated then oh this is still
interesting then move it I don't see how
i'm getting mated down on 12 seconds
let's that's the main problem just a
bullet trick why does completely winning
of course yeah I spent too much time at
the beginning of all this because I
really got under pressure after that he
got outplayed again and I was so I was
really too too far behind is still 18
minutes so some some chances left to at
least play some catch-up game k
yeah that's at stake I could have just
taken ji-sun I it's tough yeah really a
bullet is tough when you don't have any
practice I'm not really bad I pull it
but it's really a matter of how much you
play it yeah that's of course really
very a nice position with this earthy
sports and the center and then basically
just going home IAM doing a home run
Queen f8 mate i hope next Rock'em don't
let the clock run down
I let me a dis catch up a bit here yeah
gnosis is a bit much especially
considering the positions the losses
were from now he's giving me all kinds
of material here yeah I cannot probably
save the nightie anyway maybe I can be
no should be three all rights not there
and not so far off and that looks
stirred some chances to catch up these
are noise some some quick resigns can
this guy answers one guy who have played
golf game s this is quite nice of course
at nice lies bullets trick here with the
capture on f6 which is totally bonkers
this move okay now what what are you
doing with c3 it is it is just
positionally totally bad but hopes that
I don't recapture
so I just wanna learn a PCM might be for
probably not that I open up open up the
position here for my own attack I could
have taken our queen actually right okay
this is good enough Queen age 6 no don't
tell me no I don't ever check yeah what
the heck I don't have a check here this
is great yeah this is great and you're
not even Queen B 6 yeah because of the
city rukon be one unbelievable crap
here's this yes resign oh man the only
way to lose this game to fall for some
someone I'm sure that this is a great
idea playing the absolute main line of
the dragon and now and I pull it I don't
really know how it is played ok at least
I hope I'm not I'm not like totally lost
here maybe I am maybe i am now with the
rook coming here hmm
be too this that's probably yeah this is
also possible wow what an idiotic
opening choice oh my yeah this ash I'm
doing playing the absolute mainline no
cling the absolute mainline dragon
against some guy who knows the theory
yeah sometimes don't you really do
stupid things only only right after you
did them you think okay this wasn't too
clever okay at least this should be okay
with two extra answers and make the
three imma leave them how many games did
hell Austin Istanbul that's really a
lotta now pull it well it will it takes
practice it's just like that
yeah just one apanya well-known opening
line that's not great for black the tier
still has decent development so it's not
so easy to play especially with this
quick time control well so I really lost
some routine yet to play tickles I don't
really look at the opponent's ratings
and stuff which you really should do now
it's helpful to know where firm you
should go for some some sort of very
quick quick win where you yeah sometimes
can risk to play some wacky stuff or if
the opponent is really a somewhat
stronger player where you probably
should play em a bit more cautiously
this dragon for example if I would have
seen that this is a good player with
2,400 I am I would have avoided that I
guess yeah this this is nice here with
the point and earth giving away even
more cause I say come to play so I'm
catching up a bit but only a bit
Queensland en target position so not not
a very dangerous version for me I guess
now there are some weaknesses yeah but
let's coordinate it quite quite quite
well yeah I don't think that this is a
very meaningful poem 94 is coming maybe
I should have played this before even
the six I have covered but I shouldn't
take it like that maybe go here we are
now winning two points even and also a 2
is gone I need to
oops I didn't meant to give away the
beep on but okay I still a very nice
position okay let's use the apron yeah I
hope the three checkmate let's pay
attention to that I'm not playing that
well I know that badly but I put some
some very III really made some some bad
decisions with opening a choices and
stuff and I lost this one one strange
game on time yeah upon until a nice
center should be quite quite good for
wider 95 norm preventing cancelling a
queen a for coming
i take i can take 25 this capture or
numb on a b7 don't really want to trade
queens with this King wide opener this
could have been a very costly pre-move
if you would have played Quincy 7i
whoopsie 70 quite quite nice bouquet 7
made almost
ah too slow hey I'm just too slow not
even close to the top gaseum yeah i
guess i would need to to play some more
some more bullets here especially i'll
just keep a meter just to the interface
and so on it's it's always a bit
different when an animal
yeah French French exchange stuff
interesting add yeah I lost and lost the
number of new CSC five that have been
strong already didn't do that
yeah I've got some pressure that crank
used on this is to activate look the aid
can be oh forgot about this silly fork
yeah I know poo not nice yeah simply
forgot about the fork
now he does not need to play chess any
melons on time yeah sort of Freedonia
where at least them what is good
relatively easy attacking LA I should be
quite a quite nice for white here in
this position e seven was always was
also nice
is this is just one material though f5
is hanging and d7 yeah okay just need to
be precise iam
right f6 check some games like quite
okay but i also get in not enough games
image now okay let's check briefly i am
what this is is 14th yeah that's not
that's not really great but let's check
i got in 17 games which is comparable to
the other guys i mean i lost I lost her
some where is it again he on chest q
game history let me just check where why
did I lose all the games
I hear lost one and lost one on time I
think yeah where was Queen up or
something and then I like that allowed
this checkmate this was also funny when
he had one threat in the game and I
overlooked that yeah yeah you need to
get back into this this tournament
tournament stride it's a bit a bit
tricky okay well thanks for watching I
hope with some better next time